[Aplausos]
hoy quiero compartir con ustedes una
historia personal la historia de mi
superheroína mi abuela y ustedes me
preguntan quién es la persona que yo más
admiro en todo el mundo es mi abuela
claramente mi abuela fue una mujer
excepcional super inteligente siempre
entendió la importancia de la educación
como una herramienta para lograr
nuestras metas para salir adelante
mi abuela me hacía el desayuno por la
mañana me ayudaba con las tareas me
llevaba por las mañanas a esperar el
autobús cuando era pequeña para ir al
cole mi abuela siempre me animó a seguir
mis sueños a estudiar medicina pues bien
yo estudié medicina y luego me fui de
casa para estudiar neurología a los dos
años aproximadamente mi madre me
comienza a decir que mi abuela está rara
que se le olvidan las cosas
que confunde a mi padre mi abuela
adoraba a mi padre que no lo reconocía
me dice que a veces ve personas que no
están allí que oye cosas raras
estos síntomas poco a poco van a más y
luego
se hizo dependiente para todas las
actividades tenía que depender de mi
madre para todo mi madre esto lo llevaba
muy mal me decía que mi abuela se
comportaba como una niña pequeña y que
veía que estaba sufriendo después de
unos dos o tres años aproximadamente mi
abuela falleció había padecido una
demencia yo no estaba presente pero por
estadística la causa más frecuente de
demencia es la enfermedad de alzheimer
mi abuela mi superheroína padeció una
demencia por enfermedad de alzheimer y
ahora yo les pregunto a ustedes cuántos
de los que están presentes tienen o han
tenido algún familiar que haya padecido
enfermedad de alzheimer levanten la mano
y si somos muchos y si es que resulta
que cada tres segundos se diagnostica a
una persona con enfermedad de alzheimer
en el mundo y se espera que para 2050
152 millones de personas sean
diagnosticadas con esta enfermedad
esto se debe en parte al aumento de la
expectativa de vida porque como vivimos
más años con la edad aumenta el riesgo
de padecer enfermedades
neurodegenerativas como la enfermedad de
alzheimer y esto por otra parte
significa que nosotros tenemos un reto
muy importante por delante porque
tenemos que buscar tratamientos y
estrategias de cuidado para esta
enfermedad que afecta no solamente a los
pacientes sino también a los familiares
desde la fundación hace nos tomamos este
reto muy en serio y yo tengo la suerte
de formar parte de un equipo en donde
hacemos estudios de investigación con
medicamentos que se llaman ensayos
clínicos y también formo parte del
equipo de robótica social
y la verdad es que la robótica social
para mí es un campo nuevo y cuando en el
trabajo me hablaron de robots yo lo
primero que pensé fue los robots nos van
a quitar el trabajo porque porque esto
es lo que aparece en las noticias en el
periódico en el telediario porque se
sabe que para dentro de unos 15 años
aproximadamente el 40 por ciento de los
puestos de trabajo va a ser reemplazado
por la inteligencia artificial y claro
que piensa uno pues lo que están
pensando ustedes pueden rebotar ser mi
trabajo o dicho de otra forma me voy a
quedar sin trabajo porque van a
contratar a un robot en mi lugar y estas
son preguntas muy válidas porque de
hecho es cierto que la automatización va
a llevar consigo un cambio muy
importante en el mercado laboral
pero por otra parte los robots tienen un
enorme potencial para mejorar nuestra
calidad de vida y posiblemente mejorar
la calidad de vida de los pacientes con
enfermedad de alzheimer pero para hablar
de esto como un poco más de detalle voy
a invitar al escenario un amigo mío que
se llama sócrates
sócrates bienvenidos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
qué tal sócrates bienvenido muchas
gracias por venir cuéntame cómo estás
muy bien muchas gracias por invitarme a
participar en tu ex barcelona de nada
sócrates ha sido elaborado por una
empresa de aquí de barcelona y luego ha
sido modificado por el instituto de
robótica e informática industrial
cuéntanos sócrates como tú crees que
podrías ayudarnos a tratar a pacientes
que tengan deterioro cognitivo o
enfermedad de alzheimer los ingenieros
de la universidad politécnica de
cataluña me han programado con ayuda de
la fundación ac para realizar
estimulación cognitiva a personas con
deterioro cognitivo mi tarea consiste en
ayudar a los pacientes a realizar un
ejercicio cognitivo en donde tienen que
poner fichas identificadas con letras o
números en un orden específico cuando el
paciente comete un fallo yo se lo indicó
y le ayudó a identificar el error
muy bien eso me parece muy interesante y
tú cómo crees que esto puede ser
beneficioso para los pacientes que
padecen enfermedad de alzheimer la
estimulación cognitiva es muy
beneficiosa porque ayuda a mantener o
disminuir la progresión del deterioro
cognitivo además favorece la
socialización mejora el autoestima y
ayuda a ralentizar la pérdida de
autonomía del paciente muy bien
muchísimas gracias sócrates un aplauso
para sócrates es gracias
hay otra forma en la que los robots
pueden ayudarnos y eso es en la
realización de tareas de la vida
cotidiana como pueden ser por ejemplo
cocinar o en el caso de los pacientes es
tomarse la medicación estos robots se
llaman robots asistentes y estas tareas
aunque pueden parecer muy sencillas en
realidad son muy complicadas para los
pacientes que padecen enfermedad de
alzheimer debido a los problemas
cognitivos
un ejemplo de esto es un proyecto en el
cual yo participe que se llama rancik y
estas siglas traducidas del inglés
significan robot asistente a domicilio
para pacientes con deterioro cognitivo
leve rsi fue un proyecto europeo en
donde participamos personal médicos e
ingenieros de varios países de grecia
italia alemania polonia de un reino
unido y españa- y yo tuve la suerte de
formar parte del equipo de fundación
hace y con la ayuda y colaboración de
mis compañeros y de las familias y los
pacientes que nos abrieron las puertas
de sus casas pudimos probar unas
funciones que yo a continuación les voy
a demostrar aquí lo que podemos ver son
algunas de las funciones que nosotros
desarrollamos en el robot mirar una de
las funciones es la detección de caídas
en las personas mayores de 65 años que
es la población más frecuente que padece
enfermedad de alzheimer esto es un
problema y el ran shift sería capaz de
hacer la detección también es capaz de
detectar si después de que el paciente
ha cocinado ha dejado encendido en la
cocina o en este caso el microondas y
esta mano que ustedes ven así de grande
es que es súper complicada la
manipulación en los robots porque esta
mano ha tardado 14 millones de años de
evolución entonces es bastante difícil
esta es otra tarea de manipulación rasic
y sería capaz de detectar situaciones de
baja luminosidad y encender la luz
cuando el paciente se está moviendo por
casa también es capaz de recordar la
medicación esto para nosotros los
médicos es súper útil porque los
pacientes que padecen deterioro
cognitivo muchas veces tienen mal
cumplimiento terapéutico porque se
olvidan tomar la medicación o sea que
eso para nosotros sería crucial otra de
las funciones que tiene es detectar si
un objeto está mal colocado y volverlo
al sitio al que corresponde y esto
también es bastante importante porque
uno de los síntomas más frecuentes a
veces en nuestros pacientes
que nos recuerdan donde han dejado los
objetos sea que decir nos podría ayudar
en esto él es capaz de detectar si se ha
dejado abierto el refrigerador y hay que
cerrarlo otra de las tareas de
manipulación que es bastante compleja
desde el punto de vista técnico y que se
está intentando mejorar también es capaz
de recoger un objeto que se ha caído del
suelo y esto va conectado un poco con el
prevenir las caídas para evitar las
complicaciones que vienen derivadas en
las personas que son mayores de 65 años
también podría hacer el recordatorio de
beber líquidos las personas mayores
muchas veces beben muy poco líquido y se
deshidratan con más frecuencia entonces
con esto podríamos evitar la
deshidratación
otra de las funciones que tienen así es
recordar al paciente que es hora de
comer y sería capaz de llevarle el
alimento
y por último también rancik es capaz de
realizar estimulación cognitiva porque
tiene un ejercicio cognitivo y permite
hacer videollamadas con lo cual se
fortalecen los lazos de comunicación con
familiares y amigos y esto es muy
importante para mantener el estado de
ánimo de nuestros pacientes
la verdad es que racing fue una
experiencia única nosotros tenemos
anécdotas del proyecto para escribir un
libro y yo me lo pasé súper bien fue muy
divertido realizar este proyecto en
barcelona estas son algunas fotos con
nuestros pacientes y con nuestros
compañeros